[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas sur une autre planète
ces bâtiments ce sont deux méthaniseur
nous sommes à quelques kilomètres au
sud-est de dijon à brazey-en-plaine
c'est jean michel favre qui a monté
cette installation sur sa ferme il y a 6
ans pour valoriser les déchets de ses
productions bovins et céréales je suis
en train de remplir la traînée
d'incorporation pour nourrir la
méthanisation tout ce qui rentre dans la
trémie sait tout des produits agricoles
et autres banques soient des des bouts
de la malterie dons qui sont débout
assez solide qu'on incorpore aussi on
reçoit aussi des liquides cdo grâce de
restauration et des soupes de
déconditionnement tous ces déchets
passent ensuite 110 à 120 jours dans les
grandes cuves où ils fermente et dégage
un gaz le méthane
c'est lui qui permet de fournir
l'énergie donc là on est dans le local
technique où il ya le moteur
pour la cogénération donc le moteur
le gaz méthane qu'on a qu'on produit
dans les fermenteurs et
il permet d'entraîner génératrice pour
fabriquer de l'électricité
cette électricité environ 500
kilowattheures et revendue à edf
jean michel fabre a signé un contrat de
20 ans avec l'entreprise l'eau de
refroidissement est elle utilisée pour
chauffer une malterie et une sécherie
d'oignons quant aux résidus des déchets
il lui servent à fertiliser cessole ce
projet c'est avec l'aide de clément
minier de l'ademe l'agencé de maîtrise
de l'énergie qu'il a montée pour la
partie technique mais également qu'on le
valider car tous les projets ne sont pas
acceptés notre idée c'est c'est vraiment
que l'installation de méthanisation
s'adapte aux activités aux activités de
la ferme et pas l'inversé
on craint le modèle allemand qui
aujourd'hui t aujourd'hui arrêtée mais
sur lequel effectivement est un choix en
france ce qui a été fait de ne pas
développer la médiation sur ce modèle là
où il ya beaucoup de cultures dédiées
qui ont été produites pour pour les
méthaniseurs en clair pas question de
cultiver uniquement pour méthaniser à la
base il doit y avoir une vraie
exploitation agricole
c'est le cas ici à marsannay le bois au
nord de dijon ils sont même cet
agriculteur à s'être associés pour
monter une unité de méthanisation
au départ tout est parti pour eux d'un
besoin de produire autrement tout en
étant rentable financièrement
historiquement notre exploitation vous
êtes plutôt des choses très simples du
colza du blé et de l'orge est
aujourd'hui avec une volonté d'utiliser
un peu moins d'engrais un peu moins de
produits phytosanitaires
on a besoin de raincourt port et de
l'herbe dans dans nos exploitations
or l'herbe pour la valoriser le plus
simple ça pourrait être de l'élevage
sauf que c'est pas toujours facile de
faire l'élevage partout et la
méthanisation pouvait être un moyen de
valoriser cette herbe
il ya déjà des unités de méthanisation
en côte d'or mais la particularité de
cette si ça sera de produire du bio
méthane du biogaz
ce biogaz seront ensuite revendus au
grand dijon via un fournisseur d'énergie
à un prix fixe légèrement supérieur à
celui du marché
pour cette unité les agriculteurs ont
été accompagnés par la chambre
d'agriculture notamment pour faire de la
pédagogie car certains projets ont été
freinés par des riverains qui craignent
les risques d'explosion ou les odeurs
les unités de méthanisation sont sur les
exploitations les exploitations sans
général retirés sont pas au centre des
villages
donc on est haut ni plus ni moins qu'une
activité agricole
si on avait un élevage sur
l'exploitation on aurait exactement les
mêmes contraintes
le projet ici devrait aboutir courant
2021 la bourgogne franche comté me sur 5
à 10 nouvelles installations par an
[Musique]